dans cette ferme maraîchère de la montée
régie on cultive du chou des betteraves
et des courgettes Catherine Lefebvre se
fait un point d'honneur d'utiliser un
minimum de pesticides mais à des
milliers de kilomètres d'ici c'est une
autre histoire en faisant nos recherches
là pour savoir quelle pesticides on doit
utiliser quand on a vraiment besoin de
le faire on s'aperçoit que les limites
de matière résiduelles sont beaucoup
plus basses au Québec qu'ils sont aux
États-Unis ou au Mexique selon un
rapport commandé par l'Association des
producteurs maraîchers le respect des
règles d'utilisation des pesticides est
appliquée avec l'axisme aux États-Unis
et au Mexique de plus le Canada autorise
l'importation de fruits et légumes
traités avec des produits que les
agriculteurs d'ici ne peuvent pas
employer parce qu'ils n'ont pas été
homologués au pays ou parce qu'ils sont
carrément interdits si au nom de la
santé publique on dit un poivron doit ou
pas comporter le tel type de pesticides
ou d'herbicides pour la production
québécoise pourquoi on tolère un produit
de l'étranger est une norme différente
et qu'elle soit acceptée pour nous les
producteurs c'est des loyal des traces
de bifandine qui dépassent les seuils
acceptés ont par exemple été décelé dans
des fraises provenant de l'étranger
alors que ce pesticide est banni au
Canada sa bio accumulation dans les sols
et les graisses des mammifères et jugés
trop importante je veux pas on importe
quand même ces fruits là qui sont vendus
et consommés par des Québécois c'est sûr
qu'on trouve ça un peu injuste surtout
quand on se fait faire du dumping prix
très très bas
le ministère québécois de l'Agriculture
a mis en place un programme de
surveillance des fluxs et légumes vendus
en épicerie selon sa dernière analyse en
2019-2020 quatre échantillons de
produits québécois sur un total de 207
présentait des traces de pesticides
dépassant le maximum permis ce qui
représente
2%. c'est beaucoup plus élevé pour les
fruits et légumes importés 26
échantillons sur 360 se sont avérés
problématiques un taux de non-conformité
de 7%. c'est ce qu'on demande là c'est
qu'il y ait plus d'évaluations qui
soient fait au douanes quand les
produits arrivent ici là pour être
capable de les refuser c'est répondre
pour critères parce qu'après qui sont
rendus dans les tablettes il est trop
tard le mal est fait avec le
libre-échange si pratiquement la seule
façon d'empêcher l'entrée de produire en
provenance des États-Unis et du Mexique
mais au-delà des contrôles renforcés les
agriculteurs réclament une meilleure
harmonisation des normes pour se battre
armes égales
le comité permanent sur l'agriculture et
l'agroalimentaire ah il y a mis une
recommandation aux communes pour que la
réciprocité des normes soit renforcée il
faut espérer que cette recommandation là
sera bien comprise entre temps le
gouvernement du Québec se dit prêt à
épauler les agriculteurs des fois il va
arriver que des produits à l'extérieur
ça va être carrément dompé sur notre
territoire sont vraiment pas de contrôle
là-dessus ok mais par contre où on peut
intervenir c'est faire en sorte
d'accompagner nos producteurs nos
productrices pour qu'il soit de plus en
plus compétitive en plus des normes
entourant les pesticides un autre enjeu
des avantages grandement les
agriculteurs du Québec les coûts de la
main d'oeuvre
c'est connu ils sont beaucoup plus bas
au Mexique mais aussi en Californie ou
l'embauche de travailleurs sans-papiers
et répandus un travailleur quand même
assez bien rémunéré au Mexique va gagner
120$ par semaine chez moi et 37 ans et
800 dollars qui leur reste dans le poche
sont soumis aux mêmes règles que nous
travaillons au Québécois soit 15 et 25
dollars pour le salaire minimum mais les
avantages et tout ça les logements
fournis nous amènent à autour d'un 20
dollars c'est sans compter de nouvelles
exigences en trouvant l'environnement et
la gestion de l'eau qui s'accompagne
d'une montagne de paperasse on a un bon
soutien du ministère d'agriculture mais
il faut quand même que ces gens-là faire
ce qu'on prend aux autres ministères
qu'un moment donné il y a une limite à
atteindre des normes trop sévère on vit
du découragement d'ustensiles on voit
pas la fin de toutes ces exigences lol
il souhaite que les consommateurs leur
donnent un coup de pouce en se tournant
davantage vers les fruits et légumes du
Québec même s'il première fois un peu
plus cher et la question qu'on doit
supposer c'est le produit qui arrive de
l'étranger est-il cultivé dans les mêmes
attentes sociétales que on s'impose
comme société québécoise c'est certain
que de faire rouler des fraises sur 5000
km de la Californie et même plus quand
ça vient du Mexique il y a quelque chose
qui est un non-sens là-dedans selon
Michel sérieux les fraises et les autres
produits cultivés ici ont un grand
avantage sur ceux de leur concurrents
étrangers leurs fraîcheur et leurs
qualités de tous ceux qui élevé le goût
est beaucoup plus prononcé meilleur il
espère que les consommateurs s'en
souviendront une fois rendu à l'épicerie